Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out Thank You Notes.
I like to write out
Thank You Notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't we do --
I'd like to write out some
weekly Thank You Notes
right now for you guys.
Do you guys mind
if I write some out tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it!
James, can I get some Thank
You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
Wow.
-He's not in his wig.
-Yeah, he's in a good mood.
[ Laughter ]
I like his shirt.
-Yeah. It's classy.
Yeah, it's like --
It's like a rust color.
-Yeah. Let's see it again.
-Yeah.
That's beautiful, man.
He's called "Mr. Autumn."
-Yeah.
Mr. Autumn, they call him. Yeah.
-That's right.
-His shirts change
like the leaves.
-Yeah.
-It's a beautiful thing.
-Only once a year.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That's the same shirt he wore --
-Same shirt he wore last autumn.
-It just progressively
gets filthy.
-It's from the fall collection.
-Yeah. Until it falls off.
-Yeah.
-And then he's shirtless.
And then he shirtless.
-Get threadbare until it falls.
And then we know
the times have changed.
You know what I mean?
-That's the only way I know
that I'm alive, is to
see him change his clothes.
It's beautiful to see you. James
from the Roots right there.
James, can I get some
Thank You Note writing music?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow. He's an animatronic.
-Wow.
-He's, like, animatronic.
It's like he's in
the Chuck E. Cheese band.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, hay rides,
for letting me know
what Uberpool would be like
in 1835.
You go, "Oh."
[ Applause ]
"Hop on the back!"
-"Have a seat!"
-"Hay!"
-[Singsong voice] "Hay!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Adirondack chairs,
for looking like the skeleton
of a La-Z-Boy.
-Ooh!
-Spooky. Spooky.
-Hallow-e-e-een!
-Hallow-e-e-e-een!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you, space bar,
for being the manspreader
of the keyboard.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"How much space you need?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa."
-"We got it."
"We got it.
Gosh. Sit normal, bud."
Oh, this is a good one.
♪♪
Thank you, Las Vegas Aces owner
Mark Davis,
for ending the WNBA season
with a bangs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
-He did a good job.
-That's a good one.
-Yeah.
-He did a great job.
He ended with a bangs. Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, accidentally
breaking an olive-oil bottle
on the ground,
for making me go,
"You know what?
Let's just move."
"I'm not cleaning this up."
-Yeah.
-"It's gonna take me four years
to clean that up."
-Them tiny slivers of glass
all day long.
-Let's look at other --
Let's get on Zillow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Jack-o'-lanterns,
for showing me
you don't need teeth
to be happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
-Happy. Happy pumpkin.
♪♪
Thank you,
"The Golden Bachelor."
You may not win any Emmys,
but you're definitely
taking home some Grammys.
Hey. There you have it.
[ Laughter ]
Those are some Thank You Notes.
We'll be right back
with Keith Richards!